This video is made possible by Brilliant.
You'll learn more about Brilliant later in
todays video, but if you would like to learn
more about them right now, go to Brilliant.org/biographics.
You'll also find a link in the description
below!
Long before Kim Jong-Un became the go-to tyrant
for five star absurdity, there was another
dictator on the block.
Muammar al-Gaddafi ruled Libya for 42 years
with an iron fist wrapped in a sequined glove
so garish it would’ve put Liberace to shame.
His flamboyant reign was famous for its absurdity.
For every headline relating to his terrorist
activities, there were maybe a dozen more
about his plastic surgery addiction or all-female
bodyguard troupe.
By the time Gaddafi was overthrown in 2011,
he was less feared than he was simply mocked.
But behind the monstrous vanity lay a man
who was simply a monster.
Rape in Gaddafi’s Libya was institutionalized.
Mass executions were broadcast on TV.
Dissidents were executed and their bodies
kept in freezers for the self-styled “King
of All Kings” to visit at his leisure.
But such depraved behavior wasn’t created
in a vacuum, it was only thanks to Libya’s
tortured history that Gaddafi was able to
imprint his psychosis on his nation.
Today, we’re exploring how the life of the
“Mad Dog of the Middle East”.
Origins – the Boy and the Master
Most histories of Gaddafi start at the obvious
place: the sweltering June day in 1942 when
he was born in a nomad’s tent near the dusty
fishing village of Sirte.
But to really understand Gaddafi, you have
to go back further, all the way to September
28, 1911.
That’s the day Italian warships appeared
off the coast of Tripoli.
It was the beginning of the Italian occupation,
and the beginning of Libya’s very own reign
of terror.
For the next few decades, Libya was not a
nice place to be anything other than a pureblood
Italian.
Natives were worked to death in squalid labor
camps, while resistance fighters were brutally
executed in public.
The whole ghastly horror show only ended when
the Allies booted Italy from North Africa
in 1943.
By that point, over a third of all Libyans
had been murdered by their colonizers.
If Gaddafi was cruel, it’s because he was
born into a world where cruelty was the only
currency.
That being said, the boy himself missed the
worst of it.
With British help, King Idris of Cyrenaica
seized power in 1951, joining the three colonies
of Italian Libya into modern Libya and ushering
in a period of peace.
Not that young Gaddafi had it easy.
His family were poor Bedouins.
He lived in a tent.
His only formal schooling was meant to be
learning the Quran.
It’s only because he showed promise that
he was sent on to basic school.
Presumably, his family hoped he was destined
for great things.
Spoiler alert: that’s foreshadowing.
While young Gaddafi was at school, scraping
his knees and carving his name onto desks,
Libya was sinking into a mire of poverty.
King Idris was selling land to the US Army
in return for cash in his family pockets,
which was as popular as you’d expect.
While this sort of naked corruption was humiliating
for ordinary Libyans, it was just a symptom
of the broader malaise gripping the Arab world.
With culture in decline, and the rich looting
their countries, the average Arab was looking
for a champion, someone to make them feel
proud again.
Enter Nasser.
Colonel Gamal Abdel Nasser is a man who could
fill a dozen Biographics videos just by himself.
The new ruler of Egypt following a bloodless
coup in 1952, he was the guy about to light
the spark of Arab nationalism and send it
exploding across the region.
In June 1956, he finally did.
Furious with the British military presence
in his nation, and angry at the new state
of Israel on his borders, he nationalized
the British-owned Suez Canal.
So the British joined forces with France and
Israel and invaded, triggering the Suez Crisis.
The whole Suez Crisis is a beyond our scope
here, so let’s just skip ahead to the ending.
Israel, France and Britain lost the Canal.
Although their loss was more to do with the
US yelling at them “get out now, you idiots,
or you’re gonna spark WWIII!” that’s
certainly not how the Arab world saw it.
Overnight, Nasser became a sensation.
Combined with his working-class roots, poverty
reduction programs, and desire for Arab unity,
he became a hero to millions.
Among those newly inspired was teenage Gaddafi.
Still in school, he watched the Suez Crisis
unfold with the sort of mixture of awe and
excitement your parents felt watching the
moon landing.
As with so many others, Nasser’s boldness,
his ambition lit a fire in Gaddafi’s soul.
Before the Suez Crisis was over, he’d been
expelled from school for political agitation.
But if you think a simple expulsion is gonna
halt Gaddafi’s new ambition to be the Libyan
Nasser, are you in for a surprise.
The Libyan Nasser
Five years after his expulsion, young Gaddafi
managed to finagle his way into the military
academy in Benghazi.
He did so for the express reason of staging
a Nasserite coup.
Seriously, he even brought a loyal group of
school friends along with him, all of whom
donned uniform for the first time on the understanding
that they’d soon be overthrowing the government.
Albeit, not quite yet.
For eight years, Gaddafi and his co-conspirators
did nothing more than slowly rise up the army
ranks.
Gaddafi was made a captain and briefly trained
in the UK.
He met the American ambassador, who astutely
noted that the young soldier’s intelligence
was only matched by his extraordinary emotional
instability.
By 1963, Gaddafi had established a secret
Free Officers society in the army, modeled
after Nasser’s old coup-planning team.
By 1965, it had expanded its membership far
beyond his childhood friends, becoming the
army club to join.
Now convinced destiny was on his side, Gaddafi
simply needed a sign that Libya was ready
for an uprising.
In 1967, he got it.
On June 5, long-simmering tensions between
Israel and its Arab neighbors finally reached
boiling point.
The resulting Six Day War saw Israel wipe
the floor with Egypt, Syria, and Jordan while
barely breaking sweat.
For our story though, it was the reaction
in Libya that mattered.
Angered at such epic Arab humiliation, the
populace rioted.
It was the first major sign of dissent against
Idris’s rule, until now Libyans had been
almost uniquely undemonstrative in the Arab
world.
For Gaddafi’s Free Officers, it was the
sign they’d been looking for.
In August 1969, King Idris made the fateful
decision to go to Turkey for medical treatment.
While he was out the country, the Free Officers
quietly seized control.
When Libya awoke on September 1, it was to
a new regime.
The monarchy had been toppled in a bloodless
coup, and the Free Officers now ruled via
the Revolutionary Command Council, with Gaddafi
as its chair.
Aged just 27, the Bedouin boy born in a tent
became de-facto ruler of Libya.
So, given what we know about Gaddafi, how
was the coup received at the time?
Surprisingly, rather well.
Most Libyans embraced it.
While Idris had been popular with his clan,
most others felt his rule had been weak and
ineffective.
And Gaddafi wasn’t just being vain calling
himself the Libyan Nasser, ordinary Libyans
really were crying out for a pan-Arab champion
to restore their pride and drag them into
the modern world.
Even on the international scene, the reaction
was mostly warm.
Henry Kissinger was willing to accept Gaddafi’s
insistence that the US abandon its Libyan
bases on the basis that the new leader was
at least an anti-Communist.
In fact, the only group who turned out to
be unhappy with the idea of a Gaddafi-led
coup were the Free Officers themselves, who
tried to stage yet another coup in December
to replace Gaddafi.
They were quickly crushed.
As the sun dawned on the new decade, it was
on a Libya that was now totally under Gaddafi’s
control.
The Master’s Death – the Wheels Fall Off
The 1970s saw Libya get off to a fresh start
that was if not exactly good, then not utterly
terrible.
Following Nasser’s lead, the now Colonel
Gaddafi nationalized key assets like petroleum
production, made education free, and distributed
money to the poor.
Also like his hero, Gaddafi expelled the Jews,
along with all remaining descendants of the
Italian colonists.
It’s here that we get our first glimpse
of the man Gaddafi would become.
For the new Libyan leader, it wasn’t enough
that the Italians simply left, they had to
be humiliated.
He forced all those going into exile to dig
up the corpses of their dead from the graveyards
and take them with them.
That very literal caravan of death must have
been a chilling sight.
However, this was all small potatoes.
The outside world paid little attention to
Libya, even the Arab world.
At least, until September 28, 1970.
That was the day that a massive heart attack
felled Gamal Abdel Nasser.
The master was gone.
It was a tough time for the Arab world, probably
made tougher by Gaddafi’s loud instance
that he was Nasser’s heir and would lead
them all from now on.
While the Middle East mourned its hero, the
Libyan upstart began pulling all sorts of
tricks, from starting a war with Chad, to
getting thousands of Libyan youths to storm
the border with Egypt, waving petitions inked
in their own blood demanding the unification
of Libya and Egypt.
Mad as this was, there was still a chance
at this stage that Gaddafi might wind up being,
well, kinda OK.
He’d made reforms, and nationalized petroleum
meant money to spend on bribing the mostly
nomadic populace with clean drinking water
and irrigation ditches.
Yet the clues to his future madness were still
there, if you knew where to look: inside Gaddafi’s
Green Book.
Released in 1974, the Green Book remains a
work like no other.
An explanation of Gaddafi’s political philosophy,
it’s a heady mix of utopianism, Arab nationalism,
Islamism, socialism, tribal values, and a
great huge dollop of xenophobia, all thrown
together in a way that doesn’t really make
any sense.
That may be why, when Gaddafi declared Libya
the Green Book’s prophesized utopian government
the Great Jamahiriyah in 1977, only Burkina
Faso ever seemed enthusiastic.
The rest of the Arab world simply shrugged.
Well, almost.
Gaddafi’s Green Book prophesized that other
Arab powers would be so jealous of the Jamahiriyah
that they would try to destroy it.
So, in July 1977, he attacked Egypt first
before they could attack him.
Only it turned out Egypt never intended to
attack, but now they were in this war they
were damned if they were gonna lose it.
500 dead later, the world had a very good
indication that Gaddafi’s Jamahiriyah did
not intend to play nice.
The Mad Dog
By the end of the 1970s, it was clear what
way the winds were blowing.
Frustrated by the end of his dreams of becoming
the next Nasser, Gaddafi instead settled for
becoming notorious on his own insane terms.
Inside Libya, this meant a return to the repression
of the Italian era, only with a weirdness
unique to Gaddafi.
Cinemas, music concerts, and football matches
were all banned, followed by anywhere else
where people could plot against the regime.
Music was designated Western imperialism,
and a great bonfire of musical instruments
burned in Tripoli’s central square.
On the economic front, rampant corruption
led to supermarkets so empty that there were
frequent, deadly food riots.
Not that you could complain, of course.
Complaining meant becoming another victim
in the mass executions broadcast day and night
on public TV, another victim to be humiliated
then brutally slaughtered.
Gaddafi may have expelled the Italian colonizers,
but he kept the cruelest of their methods.
Outside Libya, this was also when Gaddafi
began throwing money at every extremist group
on the planet.
So it was Semtex for the IRA, weapons for
the Black Panthers, and money for the ANC.
Yes, the same ANC led by Nelson Mandela, at
that point still sitting in prison.
Remember that, ‘cause it’ll be important
later.
As 1981 shuddered into view, Libya had basically
gone mad.
The death toll of the ongoing war in Chad
was brutalizing the whole society, now also
crumbling under a British-led economic embargo.
It was around this time that Gaddafi first
appeared on American screens, when US warships
were forced to shoot down two Libyan jets
over the Gulf of Sirte.
It was the first military clash between America
and an Arab power in modern times.
As you already know, it wouldn’t be the
last.
Fast becoming an international pariah, Gaddafi
doubled down.
In the early 1980s, he made a public speech
in which he called Libyans living abroad “stray
dogs” who would be hunted down.
He also promised to bring chaos to Europe,
a promise he quickly fulfilled.
It would take the rest of our time today to
give you a running timeline of Gaddafi’s
atrocities over the next few years.
Suffice to say they were numerous and shocking.
A highlights, or maybe a lowlights reel might
go something like this:
April 1984.
A submachinegun fires out the window of the
Libyan embassy in London, injuring 11 anti-Gaddafi
protestors and killing 25 year old policewoman
Yvonne Fletcher.
December 1985.
Arab terrorists funded by Libya launch simultaneous
gun attacks on Rome and Vienna airports, killing
19 and wounding 138.
Their targets were Jewish passengers.
April 1986.
Libyan intelligence bombs a West Berlin nightclub
frequented by US soldiers.
2 soldiers and a Turkish civilian die, while
nearly 230 are injured.
It was this last one that finally made the
international community take action.
Faced with dead American soldiers, Ronald
Reagan authorized a bombing run on Tripoli,
intended to take out Gaddafi himself.
Just days after the bomb went off in Berlin,
American jets streaked across the pale blue
Libyan skies, raining missiles onto the capital.
In his compound, Mad Dog Gaddafi was shaken
to life by an enormous explosion.
Staggering outside, he supposedly found the
bomb crater that had been meant for him.
Near its smoking remains lay the torn and
bloodied body of his adopted daughter.
The American bombs may have failed in their
goal of killing the dictator, but they at
least seemed to shake him to his senses.
Attacks on Europe faltered.
In 1987, Gaddafi officially ended the war
in Chad.
In 1988, he even mimicked Gorbachev’s Perestroika
reforms in the Soviet Union, allowing capitalism
back into Libya and personally standing atop
a bulldozer that smashed down the wall of
a jail in Tripoli, freeing hundreds of political
prisoners.
At the time, it looked like a cynical ploy
for winning back the hearts of a population
he’d abused for so long.
Now we know the Mad Dog was likely just playing
for time.
Shortly after 6pm on December 21 that year,
Pan Am Flight 103 took off from Heathrow Airport
in London.
It flew upwards, over Britain, until it reached
the skies above the village of Lockerbie,
Scotland.
There, it disappeared from radar screens.
When a control tower tried to signal it, only
silence returned.
We all know what had happened.
At two minutes past seven, a Libyan bomb exploded
in the hold of Pan Am 103, killing all 259
onboard.
Flaming wreckage then crashed down onto Lockerbie,
killing a further 11 people on the ground.
In the aftermath of the bombing, it took an
international investigation two years to pin
the blame on Libya.
By that time, Gaddafi’s agents had already
downed another aircraft, the French operated
UTA Flight 772, which exploded over Niger
in 1989, killing 170.
In 1992, the UN instigated a harsh sanctions
regime against Tripoli.
It was the beginning of Gaddafi’s total
isolation from the world.
Now just before we get into the effects of
that isolation on the country, I do want to
take a moment to thank the people who make
this video possible - Brilliant.
And I know mid-roll ads are not great for
the story here, but these videos are long
so I hope you appreciate our need to have
sponsors make them possible.
Brilliant are a learning platform which teaches
through something called active learning.
I don't know if you've ever had to sit down
with a science textbook, but I have, and there
sure was a lot of "Wait, what?" and re-reading
pages 6 times and still not understanding
what's going on.
That's passive learning, and it's a slow way
to go.
There is nothing there to test you right away
so your brain sort of glosses over the information...
Again, and again...
Brilliant solves that problem with active
learning.
Brilliant give you something super short to
read, it's easy, and then you immediately
apply it to a problem.
Rinse and repeat and suddently you are understanding
all sort of stuff you didn't think you would
be!
I've been using Brilliant, and you should
go try it out just to see how facinating it
is that such complex subjects can be so easily
grapsed!
I've look at a forumla that looks impossibly
complex, but 10 minutes later (seriously)
I understand it because of Brilliant...
Support biographics by going to brilliant.org/biographics.
And now let's get back to Gadaffi and his
isolation problem.
The ‘90s – Isolation
If Gaddafi had begun 1988 trying to emulate
the reformist zeal of Gorbachev, he entered
the 1990s an isolated madman, no longer caring
what the world thought.
It’s around this time that some of the darkest
characteristics of the Mad Dog began to emerge.
There are tales of secret, soundproofed chambers
built into public buildings across Tripoli.
If Gaddafi happened to be visiting and saw
a girl he liked, she would be slipped away
and locked in these rooms until he was ready
to come and rape her.
Those who disappointed him were never heard
from again.
Those he liked might become one of his all-female
bodyguard retinue.
Then there are the young boys.
They were all underage, all pretty, in their
own way.
Kept caged beneath his compound, they formed
what became euphemistically known as “the
Services Group”, a gang of child sex slaves
the dictator could use whenever he wanted.
Finally, there are the tales of the freezers.
After the 2011 revolution, a large group of
ice rooms were discovered below Gaddafi’s
palace.
Inside each one lay some rival who’d been
killed on the Mad Dog’s orders.
Some had been there for over 25 years.
It’s said Gaddafi would often come down
here in the night, and touch their frozen
corpses, to be reminded again of his omnipotence.
Of his God-like power over life and death.
These tales don’t even begin to scratch
the surface of the regime’s horrors in the
‘90s.
There’s the day in 1996 when guards walked
into Abu Salim political prison in Tripoli,
dropped grenades into the cells, and killed
1,270 men.
Or the extreme methods used to crackdown on
those who began a tribal rebellion against
his rule in 1993.
Or the way the sanctions bit so hard that
speculating in water became punishable by
death.
All in all, Libya in the 1990s was as great
a horror show as during the Italian occupation.
Perhaps greater.
Yet Gaddafi still retained one unlikely friend.
Remember that mention of Nelson Mandela a
few moments ago?
Now free, Mandela spent most of the ‘90s
trying to talk his onetime sponsor into turning
over the Lockerbie bombers.
In 1999, the South African statesman managed
to extract both a promise to do just that
from Gaddafi, and an apology for the murder
of Yvonne Fletcher back in 1984.
But it would be a world-changing event that
finally brought Gaddafi in from the cold.
In the aftermath of 9/11, he became the first
Arab leader to offer both condolences and
practical military support to the USA.
Suddenly, in the crazy new War on Terror era,
Mad Dog Gaddafi didn’t seem such a bad guy
after all.
The Last Decade – The Statesman, and the
Revolution
For the relatives of Gaddafi’s many victims,
the Noughties were like falling through the
Looking Glass.
After Libya paid reparations to the Lockerbie
families, the UN lifted its sanctions.
Then, in 2004, Gaddafi suddenly announced
Libya was giving up all its chemical and biological
weapons.
As a reward, both the George Bush and Tony
Blair governments began encouraging business
investment in Libya.
The UK’s MI6 even kidnapped the families
of two Libyan dissidents from Bangkok and
handed them over to Tripoli with a note saying
“thank you”.
This new, international phase for Gaddafi
was marked by him formally turning his back
on the Arab world.
In a public speech, he begged God to keep
the Arabs out of Libya.
It seemed that, if he couldn’t be the Nasser
of the Arabs, then Gaddafi would settle for
being the Nasser of another people.
From the mid-2000s on, Gaddafi began laying
the ground for his final, quixotic dream:
a United States of Africa.
This Africa would have one passport, one external
border, one army… and one ruler.
Care to guess who he thought was the man for
the job?
Most African leaders unsurprisingly dismissed
the Mad Dog’s latest fantasy, but not all.
In 2008, Gaddafi managed to convince over
200 African kings and tribal chiefs to crown
him the “King of Kings” of all of Africa.
It was classic Gaddafi pageantry, but it did
have immediate consequences.
As a show of good will, he threw Libya’s
borders open to all Africans.
The result was four and a half million Arab
and Muslim Libyans resentfully being forced
to share their country with a million and
a half Christian Africans.
While the USAfrica never went anywhere, the
decade ended with Libya on its best international
footing since 1969.
In 2009, Gaddafi even managed to use his diplomatic
clout to have the Lockerbie bomber freed on
compassionate grounds.
All in all, things were looking up for the
monster of the Maghreb.
He was the longest-serving non-royal leader
on Earth.
He had friends in Europe and America.
The petro-money was pouring in.
Gaddafi in 2010 looked unstoppable.
And he might have been, were it not for an
anonymous Tunisian street vendor named Mohamed
Bouazizi.
On December 17, 2010, Bouazizi set himself
on fire to protest his harassment by Tunisian
authorities.
He died of his wounds a couple of weeks later,
but his suicide led to large-scale protests
that forced Tunisia’s autocratic ruler from
power.
The Arab Spring was here, and it was about
to hit Libya like a hurricane.
If you’re of a certain age, you may remember
what happened next.
Gaddafi was so sure his people loved him that
he was caught completely on the backfoot when
the country exploded in revolt on February
15, 2011.
Benghazi fell, then the rest of the east.
Finally aware of what was happening, Gaddafi
dropped the mask of moderation he’d worn
since 9/11.
The Mad Dog came roaring back, and he was
hungry for blood.
As the world watched on, the Libyan Army began
rolling towards Benghazi.
Those inside were trapped.
Fearing an impending massacre, NATO stepped
in.
A no-fly zone quickly turned into bombing
runs against Gaddafi’s units.
With Western airpower now on their side, the
rebels broke out of Benghazi and pushed West.
In no time at all, Gaddafi’s forces were
in retreat.
The resulting civil war lasted 8 months, and
killed somewhere in the region of 20,000 people.
In its end days, the world witnessed all of
Gaddafi’s worst impulses.
He ordered the starvation of Misurata in a
horrifying siege.
His jailers tortured prisoners to death.
His soldiers were given orders to rape civilians.
Yet Gaddafi simply couldn’t counter NATO’s
airpower.
By the end of summer, he was in hiding in
Sirte – the one time fishing village he’d
been born outside, now transformed by four
decades of his patronage into a bustling city.
On October 20, 2011, rebel fighters finally
overran its defenses.
Gaddafi was found hiding in a storm drain,
his flamboyant clothes soaked with blood and
excrement, surrounded by rubbish and cowering
like a rat.
Sadly, in Libya, cruelty still remained the
currency.
As Gaddafi whimpered “what’s this, my
sons?
What are you doing?” he was surrounded by
a jeering crowd.
One soldier took his bayonet and sodomized
the dictator with it, slicing his insides
open.
As phones were waved to record his last moments,
gunshots rang out.
The crowd panicked.
The images went blurry.
When they finally refocused, Gaddafi was dead,
nothing more than a bloodied corpse in the
back of a truck.
The first and last King of All Africa was
no more.
Today, some seven years after Gaddafi’s
unceremonious execution, Libya is a mess of
tribal conflict and deadly instability.
There are at least five groups in control
of swathes of the country, on top of countless
militia.
Over 10,000 have died since the post-Gaddafi
settlement collapsed in 2014, making it one
of the worst wars currently raging.
In the end, perhaps all Gaddafi really did
was hold his country back.
For a nation forged in the cruelty of the
Italian occupation, the cruelty of the Gaddafi
regime led only naturally to the cruelty of
today’s conflict.
Maybe under a different leader Libya could
have been something more.
As with so much in history, we will likely
never know.